what happens when technology knows more
about us than we do a computer now can
detect our slightest facial
micro-expressions and be able to tell
the difference between our real smile
and a fake one that's only the beginning
technology has become incredibly
intelligent and already knows a lot
about our internal states and whether we
like it or not we already are sharing
parts of our inner lives that's out of
our control
that seems like a problem because a lot
of us like to keep what's going on
inside from what people actually see and
we want to have agency over what we
share and what we don't we all like to
have a poker face
but I'm here to tell you that I think
that's a thing of the past
and while it might sound scary it's not
necessarily a bad thing I've spent a lot
of time studying the circuits in the
brain that create the unique perceptual
realities that we each have and now I
bring that together with the
capabilities of current technology to
create new technology that does make us
better feel more connect more and I
believe to do that we have to be ok
losing some of our agency with some
animals it's really amazing and we get
to see into their internal experiences
we get this up front look at the
mechanistic interaction between how they
respond to the world around them in the
state of their biological systems this
is where evolutionary pressures like
eating mating and making sure we don't
get eaten drive deterministic behavioral
responses to information in the world
and they get to see into this window
into their internal states and their
biological experiences it's really
pretty cool now stay with me for a
moment I'm a violinist not a singer but
the spiders already given me a critical
review
[Music]
it turns out some spiders tune their
webs like violins to resonate with
certain sounds and likely the harmonics
of my voice as it went higher coupled
with how loud I was singing recreated
either the predatory call of an
echolocating bat or a bird and the
spider did what it should it predictably
told me to bug off I love this the
spider is responding to its external
world in a way that we get to see and
know what's happening to its internal
world biology is controlling the spiders
response it's wearing its internal State
on its sleeve but us humans we're
different we like to think we have
cognitive control over what people see
know and understand about our internal
States our emotions our insecurities our
Bluffs our trials and tribulations and
how we respond we get to have our
pokerface or maybe we don't try this
with me your eye responds to how hard
your brain is working the response are
about to see is driven entirely by
mental effort and has nothing to do with
changes in lighting we know this from
neuroscience I promise your eyes are
doing the same thing as the subject in
our lab whether you want them to or not
at first you'll hear some voices try and
understand them and keep watching the
eye in front of you it's going to be
hard at first one should drop out it
should get really easy
you're going to see the change in effort
in the diameter of the pupil
intelligence technology contends our
personal data intelligent technology
depends on personal data in today's
technology and ends our personal data
intelligent technology depends on
personal data your people doesn't lie
your eye gives away your poker face when
your brain is having to work harder your
autonomic nervous system drives your
people to dilate
when it's not it contracts when I take
away when the voice is the cognitive
effort to understand that talkers it's a
lot easier I could have put the two
voices in different spatial locations I
could have made one louder you would
have seen the same thing we might think
we have more agency over the reveal of
our internal state than that spider but
maybe we don't today's technology is
starting to make it really easy to see
the signals and tells they give us away
the Malcolm ation of sensors paired with
music machine learning on us around us
in inner environments is a lot more than
cameras and microphones tracking our
external actions our bodies radiate our
stories from changes in the temperature
of our physiology we can look at these
as infrared thermal images showing up
behind me where beds are hotter and
blues are cooler the dynamic signature
of our thermal response gives away or
changes in stress how hard our brain is
working whether we're paying attention
and engaged in the conversation we might
be having and even whether we're
experiencing a picture of fire as if it
were real we can actually see people
give off heat on their cheeks in
response to an image of flame but aside
from giving away our poker Bluffs
what if dimensions of data from
someone's thermal response gave away a
glow of interpersonal interest tracking
the honesty of feelings in someone's
thermal image might be a new part of how
we fall in love and see attraction our
technology can listen develop insights
and make predictions about our mental
and physical health just by analyzing
the timing dynamics of our speech and
language picked up my microphones groups
have shown that changes in the
statistics of our language paired with
machine learning can predict the
likelihood someone will develop
psychosis I'm going to take it a step
further and look at linguistic changes
and changes in our voice that show up
with a lot of different conditions
dementia diabetes can alter the spectral
coloration of our voice changes in our
language associated with Alzheimer's can
sometimes show up
than ten years before clinical diagnosis
what we say and how we say it
tells a much richer story than we used
to think and devices we already have in
our homes could if we let them give us
invaluable insight back the chemical
composition of our breath gives away our
feelings there's a dynamic mixture of
acetone isoprene and carbon dioxide that
changes when our heart speeds up when
our muscles tense and all without any
obvious change in our behaviors all
right I want you to watch this clip with
me some things might be going on on the
side screens but try and focus on the
image in the front and the mammoth
window
[Music]
sorry about that I needed to get a
reaction I'm actually tracking the
carbon dioxide you exhale in the room
right now
we've installed tubes throughout the
theater and lowered to the ground
because co2 is heavier than air but
they're connected to a device in the
back but lets us measure in real-time
with high precision the continuous
differential concentration of co2 the
clouds and the sides are actually the
life the real-time data visualization of
the density of our co2 you might still
see a patch of red on on the screen
because we're showing increases with
larger colored clouds with larger
colored areas of red and that's the
point where a lot of us jumped it's our
collective suspense driving a change in
carbon dioxide alright now watch this
with me one more time
[Music]
you knew it was coming but a lot
different when we changed the creator's
intent changing the music and the sound
effects completely alter the emotional
impact of that scene and we can see it
in our breath suspense fear joy all show
up as reproducible visually identifiable
moments we broadcast a chemical
signature of our emotions it is the end
of the pokerface our spaces our
technology we'll know what we're feeling
we will know more about each other than
we ever have we get a chance to reach in
and connect the experience and
sentiments that are fundamental to us as
humans in our senses emotionally and
socially I believe it is the era of the
empath and we are enabling the
capabilities that true technological
partners can bring to how we connect
with each other and with our technology
if we recognize the power of becoming
technological empaths
we get this opportunity where technology
can help us bridge the emotional and
cognitive divide and in that way we get
to change how we tell their stories we
can enable a better future for
technologies like augmented reality to
extend our own agency and connect us at
a much deeper level
imagine a high school counselor being
able to realize that an outwardly cheery
student really was having a deeply hard
time we're reaching out could make a
crucial positive difference or
authorities being able to know the
difference between someone having a
mental health crisis and a different
type of aggression and responding
accordingly or an artist
knowing the direct impact of their work
leo tolstoy defined his perspective of
art by whether what the creator intended
was experienced by the person on the
other end
today's artists can know what we're
feeling but regardless of whether it's
art or human connection
today's technologies will know and can
know what we're experiencing on the
other side and this means we can be
closer and more authentic but I realize
a lot of us have a really hard time with
idea of sharing our data and especially
the idea that people know things about
us that we didn't actively choose to
share anytime we talk to someone
look at someone or choose not to look
data's exchanged given away that people
use to learn make decisions about their
lives and about ours I'm not looking to
create a world where our inner lives are
ripped open and our personal data and on
privacy given away to people in entities
where we don't want to see it go but I
am looking to create a world where we
can care about each other more
effectively we can know more about when
someone is feeling something that we
ought to pay attention to and we can
have richer experiences from our
technology any technology can be used
for good or bad transparency to
engagement and effective regulation are
absolutely critical to building the
trust for any of this but the benefits
that empathetic technology can bring to
our lives are worth solving the problems
that make us uncomfortable and if we
don't we'll be there too many
opportunities and feelings we're going
to be missing out on thank you
[Applause]
[Music]